Melbourne has been the most livable city
in the world
for the past seven years but this year
it lost the top spot to Vienna home to
Strauss and Schubert and famous for its
coffee houses Vienna scored an almost
perfect 99.1 percent but what makes a
city liveable the economist intelligence
unit has been analyzing this it has
ranked 140 systems according to
stability education health care
infrastructure and culture and
environment most livable cities tend to
be mid-sized in wealthy countries and
have low population densities Copenhagen
is the only other European city in the
top ten Australia in Canada each have
three cities and Japan to Western Europe
and North America are the most livable
regions in the world the Middle East and
Africa the least while Asia and
Australasia are home to some of the
world's most liveable and unlivable
cities
many factors impact how livable a city
is like natural disasters hurricanes air
ma and Maria destroyed much of Puerto
Rico this year the capital San Juan fell
further in rank than any other city the
ending of Ivory Coast's 13-year UN
peacekeeping mission demonstrated a step
toward stability and a steady increase
in its livability the rankings of cities
like Damascus Lagos Karachi and Tripoli
showed the extent to which conflict
contributes to low livability schools
and Caracas the least livable city in
Latin America is only set to get worse
owing to the deepening economic crisis
and rising authoritarianism in Venezuela
mega cities like London Paris and New
York have higher levels of crime
congestion and public transport problems
which keep them out of the top spots
this year the world overall has become a
better place to live this is because of
the decrease in terrorism threats
specifically in Western Europe vienna's
increased stability is what has given at
the edge this year
you